♪♪
Shouldn’t all that matters be...
the moment we’re living in right
now?
No.
(Phone ringing)
Hi, this is Joshua Corman.
Josh Corman sounds sort of like
Joseph Gordon.
He’s not me,
but I started imagining what my
life could have been like.
So, what do you do?
I teach 5th grade.
Shut up, I love you.
Joseph:
Having him be a teacher
was something that I’ve always
kind of wanted to do.
And the story of Mr. Corman is
Joseph:
what if some things had turned
out a little different in my life.
David:
Punch buggy!
- Okay!
- David.
You have always had something
against David.
I don’t have anything against
David, he’s just a bad person.
He’s seven.
Yeah, but you can be a bad person
when you’re seven.
♪♪
Joseph:
Josh had certain ideas about
what he thought his life
Joseph:
was going to be like as he
arrived in adulthood
Joseph:
that haven’t panned out
and he's kind of wrestling with
that.
Well I wouldn't have agreed to go
on a date with... an actual
musician.
Right, well then I'm your
guy...(Nervous laugh)
Joseph:
What I was trying to do
when I was writing the show
Joseph:
was just trying to be honest and
true and real.
(Screams)
That’s universal. We’re all
trying to figure out who we are,
where we fit.
Victor:
What’s bothering you?
Every thought that I have I’m
like, did I lock my car?
Should I go check?
But, what if I trip on my way to
check?
So then should I just leave my
car unlocked?
Wow, we went...I think we went
too narrow on that one.
Even like the saddest moments
have a bit of comedy
to it and I don’t think this
show shies away from that.
(Laughing)
Woman:
That’s not funny.
(Laughing)
Obviously it is, come on.
That’s why it strikes me as so
real and genuine.
Josh is someone who just loves
his creativity,
you know, his music.
♪♪
Juno:
Music is an important theme all
the way through
Juno:
because it is something that
Josh really cares about
and ultimately, I suppose walked
away from.
From dark times comes great art,
as they say.
Do they say that?
♪♪
Playback one more time.
Joseph:
I created the show, you could
say.
I wrote it and directed it.
-Great.
-Yo.
Joseph:
But definitely took a whole
bunch of
Joseph:
other incredibly talented
artists to make it.
Joseph:
It wasn’t just me.
Jason:
One of things that is so special
about working with Joe
is that he has this huge amount
of respect for everyone around
him.
Movie making is ultimately
collaborative.
Man:
Good shot.
Joseph:
And the more collaborators
I brought in, the better the
show got.
(Laughing)
I have it really good.
It just... it doesn’t always
feel that way, I guess.
Ruth:
Well, whose fault is that?
Thanks, Mom.
♪♪